Sie haben sich entschieden, in Aktien zu
investieren und damit auch für die
Möglichkeit, Ihrem Geld langfristig
deutlich höhere Erträge zu erzielen als
mit klassischen Sparprodukten. Wenn Sie
noch nie ein Wertpapier, eine Aktie
gekauft haben, stehen sie als Anfänger
aber wahrscheinlich vor einer Reihe von
Fragen - die wichtigsten beantworten wir
in diesem Video. Erste Frage: wie viel
Geld investiere ich? Eine konkrete Zahl
werden Sie von mir jetzt natürlich nicht
hören, aber ich nenne ein paar Grundsätze,
mit denen Sie dann selber die Antwort
für sich finden können. Erstens:
investieren Sie nicht alles, was Sie
übrig haben ins erste Wertpapier. Zuerst
sollten Sie überhaupt mal eine schlüssige
Reserve bilden. Wenn Sie die Aufgabe noch
nicht erledigt haben, bitte zurück auf
Los und erstmal unser vorheriges Video
"5 Tipps für den Vermögensaufbau"
anschauen. Wenn Sie eine flüssige Reserve
haben, dann Tipp 2: investieren Sie in das
erste Wertpapiere nur einen Geldbetrag,
den Sie nicht eher kurzfristig für
einen konkreten Anlass brauchen. Am
Aktienmarkt gibt es immer Schwankungen,
die Kurse können steigen aber auch
fallen. Wenn Sie jetzt einen bestimmten
Betrag eingeplant haben für den Autokauf
im nächsten Jahr, dann sollten Sie den
jetzt nicht an der Börse investieren.
Dritter Punkt: Investieren Sie erst mal
nur so viel, dass der Verlust dieses
Betrags Ihren Lebensstandard nicht all
zu sehr beeinträchtigen würde.
Wenn Sie eine Aktie kaufen, in ein
Unternehmen investieren, dann kann dieses
im schlimmsten Fall pleite gehen und
Ihre Aktie kann wertlos werden. Man
spricht dann von einem Totalverlust. Der
sollte Sie, wenn Sie mit dem Investieren
anfangen, nicht gleich so schmerzen, dass
Sie danach sagen, ich kaufe nie mehr eine
Aktie. Vierter Tipp: Investieren Sie nur
einen Teil des verfügbaren Geldes, das Sie
zum Investieren haben, in das erste
Wertpapier. Dann haben Sie nämlich im
besten Fall Geld übrig, um weitere Aktien
zu kaufen und das ist dann schon der
erste Schritt zur Diversifikation, also
zu einer breiter gestreuten Anlage aus
mehreren Aktien.
[Musik]
Wann soll ich einsteigen? Grundsatz
hierbei sollte sein: lieber so früh wie
möglich investieren, als lange auf den
vermeintlich richtigen Zeitpunkt zu
warten.
Es gibt dazu den bekannten Spruch: "Time
in the market beats timing the market". Was
besagt der? Als Anleger fahren Sie in der
Regel besser, wenn Sie über lange Zeit
investiert sind, als wenn Sie lange Zeit
an der Seitenlinie stehen und auf den
vermeintlich besten Zeitpunkt warten -
also zum Beispiel auf den Crash, nachdem
dann Aktien besonders günstig sind.
Aktienkurse bewegen sich in einem Auf
und Ab.
Der Verlauf ist nicht zuverlässig
vorhersagbar, auch nicht für Profis. Und
das heißt, durch Abwarten laufen Sie
immer auch Gefahr, gute Tage an der Börse
und somit auch einen Teil der Rendite zu
verpassen. Dazu gibt es Untersuchungen.
Beispielhaft hat die US-Investmentbank
JP Morgan ausgerechnet, was passiert, wenn
ein Anleger 10.000 US Dollar in den US
Aktienindex S&P 500 investiert über 20
Jahre.
Wenn er die ganze Zeit investiert war,
dann hat er im Jahr im Schnitt sechs
Prozent Rendite mit dem Geld erzielt.
Wenn er nur die zehn besten Tage in
diesem Zeitraum verpasst hat, dann hat er
am Ende nur eine jährliche Rendite von
2,4 Prozent erzielt. Das heißt, das
Verpassen der zehn Tage kostet ihn mehr als
die Hälfte seines Ertrags. Dieses
Beispiel ist natürlich zugespitzt, denn
wer abwartet der verpasst mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht nur die besten
Börsentage, sondern auch einige der
Schlechtesten. Aber das Beispiel zeigt
dadurch besonders greifbar, was im
schlimmsten Fall passieren kann, wenn Sie
eben nicht investieren, sondern abwarten.
Zudem: mittlerweile gibt es ja auch
Aktien-Sparpläne - Das heißt, Sie kaufen
nicht zu einem Zeitpunkt, sondern Sie
wählen einen Betrag x und investieren
Monat für Monat in Bruchstücke der
gewählten Aktie. Und durch so einen
Aktien-Sparplan werden Überlegungen über
den vermeintlich richtigen
Einstiegszeitpunkt ohnehin noch
unwichtiger.
Dritte Frage: Welche Aktien kaufe ich? Da
werden Sie jetzt von mir natürlich keine
Firmennamen hören, aber ich möchte Ihnen
auch einen Grundsatz mitgeben und der
lautet: kaufen Sie nur was Sie verstehen.
Das heißt, schauen Sie sich an, was stellt
das Unternehmen her, dessen Aktie Sie
kaufen wollen, beziehungsweise welche
Dienstleistungen bietet es an und auf
welchen Märkten? Also, wie breit ist es
aufgestellt? Ist es von einem
Markt abhängig? Bietet es eine ganze
Produktpalette an oder nur ein
spezielles Produkt? Machen Sie sich davon
selber ein Bild, studieren Sie mal den
Geschäftsbericht, verfolgen Sie, was in
den Medien über dieses Unternehmen
berichtet wird und legen Sie sich Ihr
eigenes Set an Kriterien zu - das können
Kennzahlen sein, das können qualitative
Kriterien sein. Entscheidend ist, sich
selber ein Bild zu machen und eben nicht
blind auf Hypes aufzuspringen, nur weil
alle gerade davon sprechen oder weil ein
vermeintlicher Top-Analyst in der
Werbung im Internet Ihnen eine bestimmte Aktie
empfiehlt. Und die Frage, welche Aktien
soll ich kaufen, die ist langfristig
gesehen zumindest ohnehin falsch
gestellt. Es ist schön, mit einer
anzufangen. Für viele ist es auch der
erste Einstieg in ihr Leben als Anleger.
Sie sollten aber relativ schnell ins
Diversifizieren kommen, also sich nicht
nur breit informieren, sondern auch breit
investieren.
Sie fangen mal mit einer Aktie an, mit dem
nächsten Geld, das Sie verfügbar haben,
kaufen Sie in eine zweite, dann eine
dritte. Und denken Sie auch über den Kauf
von ETFs nach, also börsengehandelten
Indexfonds, denn da können Sie mit nur einem
Kauf und schon einer niedrigen Summe breit
streuen und gleich im ganzen Korb von
Aktien investieren.
Vierte Frage: Wo kaufe ich Aktien? Klar,
an der Börse. Aber jetzt ist ja die Börse
kein Ort, an denen Sie direkt selber
hinfahren als Privatanleger.
Sie erhalten zur Börse Zugang über Ihre
Bank oder über einen Broker. Bei der
Auswahl eines solchen Brokers sollten Sie
auf ein paar Dinge achten. Erstens
schauen Sie sich die Auswahl an.
Also, gibt es dort in ausreichender
Anzahl Aktien, ETFs, Fonds, die Sie kaufen
möchten? Wird dort das Spektrum an
Wertpapieren abgedeckt, für das Sie
sich interessieren?
Zweitens schauen Sie sich die Gebühren
an. Also, wenn eine Order relativ viel
Geld kostet, dann fällt es gerade bei den
anfangs vielleicht gering Ordersummen
besonders ins Gewicht.
Dieses Geld ist dann weg und das muss
die Aktie, die Sie kaufen, erst wieder
einspielen. Beim Scalable Broker
beispielsweise gibt es eine Trading
Flatrate, d.h. die einzelne Order kostet da
nichts.
Dritter Punkt: Achten Sie auf eine
einfache Nutzbarkeit. Also sind die Order
Masken für Sie leicht verständlich oder
sind die kompliziert? Auf welchen
Plattformen können Sie handeln? Der Scalable
Broker beispielsweise ermöglicht es,
dass Sie sowohl über eine Weboberfläche
vom heimischen PC handeln als auch über
Ihr Smartphone von unterwegs.
Fünfte und letzte Frage: Was muss ich
denn dann jetzt tun, um loszulegen?
Das ist nicht aufwendig oder kompliziert,
da kann ich Sie beruhigen. Es sind nur
wenige Schritte.
Erstens eröffnen Sie bei dem von Ihnen
gewählten Broker ein Depot. Das dauert
in der Regel nur wenige Minuten.
Zweiter Schritt ist, zahlen Sie dort Geld
ein, weil Sie brauchen ja ein verfügbares
Guthaben, um erstmal zu handeln.
Das geht in der Regel per Überweisung
oder auch per Lastschrift. Dritter Punkt:
Machen Sie sich im Anschluss mit den
Orderarten vertraut, also den Arten wie
Sie dann Wertpapiere kaufen und
verkaufen können.
Auch hierzu haben wir schon mal ein
Video gedreht. Vierter Punkt ist dann:
wählen Sie die Aktie aus, die Sie kaufen
möchten und kaufen Sie die oder
schließen den Sparplan darauf ab und
dann liegt wenig später Ihr erstes
Wertpapier in Ihrem Depot. Wenn dann das
erste Wertpapiere in Ihrem Depot liegt, noch
ein abschließender Tipp: bleiben Sie
entspannt, auch bei zwischenzeitlichen
Kursverlusten. Investieren ist wie
angesprochen ein langfristiges Projekt. Das
heißt bei zwischenzeitlichen
Kurseinbrüchen müssen Sie nicht gleich
nervös werden. Damit wünsche ich Ihnen
jetzt viel Erfolg bei den ersten
Schritten an der Börse und beim Kauf des
ersten Wertpapieres!
[Musik]